En este video veremos el concepto de Cardinalidad
de un conjunto y diferentes clases de conjuntos.
Pero para empezar este video, quiero recordar que
un conjunto es una colección de cosas u objetos.
Puede ser una colección de superhéroes, de cactus,
de gatitos, de números o también de conjuntos;
y un conjunto puede ser cualquier cosa: una
lista de reproducción de tus canciones favoritas,
un grupo de mejores amigos, un equipo de ensueño
con tus jugadores favoritos o una colección con
las series y el anime que más te gustan, cualquier
cosa. Una forma de representar un conjunto
es encerrar sus elementos entre llaves. Por
ejemplo, podemos decir que este es el conjunto A,
este es el conjunto B, este es el conjunto C,
este, el D y este, el E. Ahora bien, muchas veces
queremos saber el número de cosas u objetos
que tenemos en un conjunto, a este número se
le denomina Cardinal de un conjunto: el número de
objetos que hay en un cierto conjunto. Si decimos
que este conjunto de superhéroes es el conjunto
A, entonces denotamos el cardinal con una barra
vertical a cada lado del nombre, justo así; pero
también se utilizan n(A) o card(A) o #(A). Pero
nosotros vamos a usar esta anotación. ¿Cuántos
superhéroes tenemos en el conjunto A? Bueno,
tenemos tres, entonces el cardinal de A es 3.
Ahora bien, para este conjunto B de cactáceas,
¿cuál es el cardinal? Vamos a contar 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, entonces tenemos 7 cactáceas,
el cardinal de B es 7. Hagamos lo mismo
para este conjunto de gatitos, ¿cuál es
el cardinal de C? ¡Contémoslos! 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, entonces aquí también tenemos un cardinal de 7,
porque tenemos 7 gatitos. Y para este conjunto de
números, ¿cuántos elementos tenemos en él? Bueno,
tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
entonces el cardinal de D es 10. Por último,
pero no por eso menos importante, está el conjunto
E. ¿Cuántos conjuntos tenemos en el conjunto E?
Pausa el video e intenta responder. Bueno, tenemos
3: este conjunto que contiene el 1, este otro que
contiene el 2 y el 3 y este otro que contiene
el 4 y el 5, entonces el cardinal de E es 3.
Si dos conjuntos tienen el mismo cardinal,
la misma cardinalidad, aunque sus objetos no
sean los mismos, decimos que son equipotentes. Por
ejemplo aquí, el conjunto A y E son equipotentes,
el conjunto B y C son equipotentes. Muy bien.
Ahora, hablemos de algunos tipos de conjuntos
básicos en las matemáticas. Primero hablaremos del
Conjunto universal, que también se le conoce como
el Conjunto universo. El Conjunto universal es el
conjunto que contiene todos los posibles objetos
en un determinado contexto, es decir, el conjunto
universo es relativo a los objetos de los que
estemos hablando. Por ejemplo, pueden ser todas
las personas de tu país, todos los árboles de tu
colonia, los números naturales o la cantidad de
estrellas en la Vía Láctea. Al conjunto universal
se le denota con la letra U mayúscula, sólo hay
que tener cuidado de no confundirlo con la unión
de dos conjuntos que veremos en otros videos. Por
ejemplo, si tenemos como universo las vocales del
abecedario, ya sabemos que ese conjunto contiene
la letra a, la e, la i, la o y la u, por lo tanto,
en este caso, el cardinal del universo es 5. Si
decimos que el conjunto universal son los planetas
del Sistema solar, entonces ¿cuál es su cardinal?
Pausa el video y piénsalo. Bien, podemos pensar en
ese conjunto como Mercurio, Venus, Tierra, Marte,
Júpiter, Saturno, Urano, Neptuno, por lo tanto su
cardinalidad es 8. Si decimos que el conjunto
universal son los números naturales, entonces
tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6... ¡son muchos! En este
caso, ¿cuál será el cardinal de U? Pausa el video
y responde. Bueno, como tenemos una infinidad
de números naturales entonces su cardinal será
infinito. Podemos tener conjuntos finitos e
infinitos. Ahora, si tenemos un conjunto con un
solo elemento decimos que es un Conjunto unitario,
por ejemplo, podemos pensar en el conjunto M
como el conjunto de los satélites naturales de la
Tierra. Bueno, este es un conjunto unitario ya que
la Luna es el único satélite natural de la Tierra,
por lo tanto, podemos decir que su cardinal es 1.
Cualquier conjunto cuyo cardinal sea 1 es un
conjunto unitario. Si pensamos en el conjunto
S como el conjunto de los números Tales que...
este símbolo representa Tal que... 2 por 5 es
igual a N, entonces ¿qué números formarán ese
conjunto? Pausa el video y piénsalo. Bueno, ese
es un conjunto unitario, ya que 2 por 5 siempre es
10, es decir, ése es el conjunto que sólo contiene
al 10. Otro conjunto que es importante definir es
el Conjunto vacío. Contrario al Conjunto universal
el Conjunto vacío no contiene ningún elemento u
objeto. Comúnmente se denota con este símbolo,
o con llaves sin nada dentro. Observa: es un
conjunto que no contiene ningún elemento y,
por lo tanto, su cardinal es... Pausa el
video una última vez y piénsalo. ¡Muy bien!,
¡la respuesta es 0!, el cardinal del conjunto
vacío es 0. Nos vemos en el siguiente video